de l'extérieur le west edmonton mall n'a
rien lâché de l'architecturé mais à
l'intérieur c'est assez impressionnant
[Musique]
vous pouvez y siroter une boisson
rafraîchissante en regardant les gens
sauter dans la piscine à vagues très
agréable dans les faits moins 30 degrés
dehors vous pouvez vous promener sur le
boulevard e repas ou encore observer des
otaries en train de danser une pratique
critiquée par les dans les romans
tanière le west edmonton mall compte
aussi des centaines de magasins lui
glissant au total
mais dès son ouverture dans les années
80 le western comme on l'appelle ne mise
pas que sur le magasinage et pour ceux
résidant dès demain tonnes qui a
documenté l'histoire du west end c'est
ce qui en fait le centre commercial
avant gardiste des centres commerciaux
qui vivent aujourd'hui des difficultés
financières avec la constitution
l'internet ils ne peuvent plus être
simplement un endroit au magazine
l'ouest est non seulement lui a compris
ce ya plus de 30 ans en fait la première
personne à l'avoir compris cette idée
c'est lui victor groulx est le créateur
du centre commercial moderne c'est un
autrichien qui a émigré aux états unis
dans les années 30 il a construit près
de minneapolis en 1956 le premier centre
commercial fermé où l'on passait d'un
magasin à l'autre sans sortir dehors et
pour victor o n le sens commercial ça
devait être un lieu de vie de rencontres
ont trouvé loisirs et services publics
des appartements même sauf que ces
plantes ont vite été abandonnée
rapidement les promoteurs immobiliers
ont compris que ce qu'ils avaient de
grandes capacités de payer c'est lé
détail 1 on a donc décidé de d'éliminer
les autres fonctions qui étaient moins
disons lucrative mais aujourd'hui on
voit que la
la roue est en train de tourner
et en 2018 les centres commerciaux qui
sont les plus à risque ce ne sont pas
les grands centres où l'on trouve une
concentration de marques populaires ceux
qui sont le plus en danger c'est les
plus petits étaient généralement à une
extrémité de sentein supermarchés et à
l'autre extrémité un magasin à rayons
une des tendances actuellement c'est de
remplacer ces grands espaces la part de
résidence personnes âgées oui c'est
maintenant pas de résidence pour
personnes âgées mais un hôtel où on peut
rester plusieurs nuits louis gallois au
gast oui oui il ya des défis importants
à l'air de l'achat en ligne il faut
constamment se renouveler se moderniser
et c'est clair qu'à certains endroits le
west est maintenant n'a pas très bien
voire soyouz souhaite aujourd'hui bien
des gens edmonton se sont habitués aux
east aides ne sont plus impressionnés
par son envergure
contrairement aux touristes qui ne
viennent pas ici souvent 50% de la
clientèle du western vient d'ailleurs de
l'extérieur dès demain tonnes comme
michel on change un visiteur de
terrebonne si tu viens maintenant tu
viens pas boire ce nom comme je l'aï
regardé le west edmonton mall n'est
peut-être pas la faire de tous mais son
pouvoir d'attraction est toujours bien
présent si laurence par radio canada